a family has to sacrifice one of their
own to save the world can they do it
here's what happens after three people
here a knock at the cabin knock at the
cabin centers around a choice that's
posed to couple Andrew and Eric and
their young daughter Wen four strangers
arrive at the cabin where Andrew Eric
and Gwen are staying and take control of
the house they tie up Andrew and Eric
and tell them that the four of them have
been United by a shared vision of an
apocalyptic event that will end Humanity
if a choice isn't made Andrew Eric and
Gwen are tasked with picking which one
of them will be sacrificed to stop the
world from ending every time the family
says no to the sacrifice one of the four
strangers dies and a deadly plague gets
Unleashed on the world if it gets to the
point where all four of the strangers
die then Andrew Eric and Wen will live
only long enough to watch the rest of
the world burn around them it's a
dilemma that at one point is described
as an impossible choice and it leads to
Bloodshed as Andrew and Derek each
wrestle with believing the strangers and
finding a way out
Central choice in knock at the cabin is
an example of a common ethics thought
experiment called the trolley problem
this scenario imagines someone being
told that a trolley's brakes have failed
and it is barreling towards a group of
people tied to the tracks this bystander
has the chance to intervene and flip a
switch that would send the trolley on an
adjacent track where it would kill just
one person in knock at the cabin Andrew
Eric and Wen deal with this dilemma it's
fitting that Leonard the leader of the
four strangers defines this as an
impossible Choice after all it's not
just about numbers these three
characters are forced to measure the
weight of their own lives against the
lives of anonymous strangers knock the
cabin elevates the trolley problem to a
grander and more emotional scale which
is partly why the film is so engaging
and relatable as Eric and Andrew refuse
to make the choice and the stranger's
deaths unleash horrifying plagues on
Humanity viewers get to see Andrew and
Eric's life together before this
encounter a series of flashbacks shows
Eric and Andrew going to adopt when
Andrew being attacked at a bar by a
homophobic Patron and the three of them
arriving at the cabin so what's the
importance of these flashbacks
ultimately they embody the reason that
Eric and Andrew simply can't sacrifice
one of their own from dealing with
disapproval from their parents and the
outside world to becoming parents
themselves these two have been through a
lot together there's a deep love between
Andrew and Eric that's hard to break
which Leonard even acknowledges I
believe you were chosen because your
families love for each other is so pure
these flashbacks play a pivotal role in
helping viewers understand Eric and
Andrew's inability to make this Choice
even as they are told the consequences
throughout knock at the cabin Andrew is
the voice of reason he refuses to
believe what the strangers are saying
and his strong-willed logic leaves
viewers unsure of what's real for
example Andrew points out that the news
broadcasts the strangers show them which
depict apocalyptic events could have
simply been carefully timed perhaps
these news stories were already in the
works and this could just be a matter of
the strangers knowing what was going to
happen beforehand and using that
information to scare the family more
significantly Andrew believes that they
have been targeted because he and Eric
are gay he thinks that Redmond might be
the man who attacked him at the bar his
conviction is so strong that he gets
Sabrina and Adrian to doubt their own
beliefs however as it becomes clearer
that there might be more at play than
Eric and Andrew initially thought
Andrew's logical thinking reveals itself
to be a cover for the fear he's feeling
about the inevitable Andrew is arguably
the most complex and compelling
character due to the way he makes
viewers question their own beliefs it
doesn't matter none of us believe you
during the first ritual sequence where
the strangers kill Redmond in order to
release a plague Eric notices something
in the light shining through the window
in a quick Flash the light-filled Visage
of a figure can be seen throughout the
film era questions what he saw and if it
was real or just a byproduct of his
concussion as the truth is unveiled it
becomes clear that this figure in the
light wasn't just a figment of Eric's
imagination it's never explicitly said
who or what Eric saw but based on the
themes of the film we can consider
different interpretations of it knock at
the cabin centers around the question of
belief and what happens when our beliefs
of the world and its rules get
challenged Andrew's world view holds no
room for even the possibility that what
the strangers are saying is true Eric is
less sure of himself so perhaps this
figure of light is a mystical being or
even God coming down to earth to try to
convince him that there's something more
happening now for the million dollar
question will the world really end if
air Eric and Andrew refused to sacrifice
one of their own the answer shockingly
is yes while it initially seems like
maybe Andrew was right and that the
stranger's Visions were just delusions
it becomes clear that they weren't lying
once Leonard is the only one left when
Leonard is the last stranger left he
shows Eric and Andrew a newscast of
hundreds of planes crashing out of the
sky at this point both the characters
and viewers realize that it's a bit too
far-fetched to believe that the
strangers coordinated something on that
scale it's enough to make anyone believe
that this isn't a hoax after all Eric
and Andrew are stunned by this
Revelation and are left with one more
choice to try and stop the world from
ending Dave Batista's incredible
performance as Leonard sells this
shocking twist perfectly In This Moment
the weight of every disaster that's
happened throughout the film crashes
down on you M Night Shyamalan doesn't
follow this up with some other twist
that disproves this sudden realization
so it's really true the things the
strangers said would happen are
happening and because Eric and Andrew
struggled to believe them the world is
now on the verge of ending will you make
a choice when Leonard finds himself as
the only stranger remaining he decides
to have one last exchange with Eric and
Andrew outside the cabin he further
divulges his motivations for coming to
them and what he saw in the Visions
Leonard describes the visions of the
Apocalypse as nightmarish and says he
felt completely helpless seeing the
world burn that sense of dread and the
heart-wrenching idea that the ones that
Leonard loves would perish in a fiery
apocalypse drove him to lead this small
group of seers now it's all he thinks
about since the world is on the brink of
destruction after spilling his guts this
last time to Eric and Andrew he asks
them if they'll make the choice although
the audience isn't shown their response
Leonard's actions say it all Leonard
draws a knife and says that Humanity has
been judged before before taking his own
life it's a subtle but powerful shift as
up until now Leonard and the other
strangers have talked about the world
facing judgment which could go either
way here Leonard as the last stranger
standing makes a definitive statement
that seems to seal Humanity's fate with
his death Eric and Andrew have mere
minutes to make a choice to try to stop
the end at first glance the four
strangers that arrive at the cabin seem
like four ordinary people when they
first introduced themselves to Eric
Andrew and Gwen they talk about their
lives so it's tough not to wonder why
they were chosen and if they serve a
greater purpose shortly after Leonard
dies and Eric gains immense Clarity he
comes to the conclusion that they do
Eric believes that based on everything
that's happened and the distinct
qualities that each of the strangers has
these four people embody The Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse in the Book
of Revelations The Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse are seen as the harbingers of
the end of time and each symbolizes a
different end of humanity Conquest War
famine and death here though Eric
interprets each stranger as a positive
quality of humanity rather than as a
means to attend for instance Leonard
personifies guidance as seen in the way
he leads the group and in his background
as a teacher
he didn't have to be like this but now
that the four of them have been snuffed
out Humanity's best qualities are gone
with them leaving the world open to
destruction it's a crushing realization
overall that not only gives deeper
meaning to the four strangers but also
makes Eric realize that a choice needs
to be made with only minutes left until
the world's fate is sealed Eric offers
himself up to be sacrificed over the
course of the film Eric has become the
most connected with the strangers and
has been less resistant to their mission
than Andrew that plus his experience of
seeing the figure in the light has
opened him up to the truth of what's
Happening even if he wishes it weren't
so he comes to see that the only way for
when to live a full life is for him to
make the choice there was something in
the light Eric is in a clearer State of
Mind than Andrew and has found a
euphoric piece in thinking about Andrew
and when and their future together Eric
delivers a monologue that pairs with a
Flash Forward which shows viewers
exactly what he hopes for Andrew and
when both older laughing together it's
the last memory he wants to think about
before his death Eric is ready to make
the sacrifice that will give the ones he
loves a chance at a real future in an
imperfect World although Andrew
struggles at first he eventually finds
the strength to shoot Eric in the chest
thus with Eric's sacrifice the choice is
made
so with Andrew and Eric making their
choice and Eric dying to save his family
the only question that remains is was it
in time at first it doesn't seem like it
since the skies are still dark and
stormy lightning strikes all around
Andrew as he climbs into the Treehouse
to see when it feels like the world is
collapsing around them and the two of
them weep over the loss of Eric the two
of them head to a local Diner where they
discover that Eric's sacrifice came just
in time to save the world at the diner
Andrew and Wen see news reports about
The disasters stopping the water from
the tsunamis start to recede those
affected by viral outbreak begin to
recover and planes stop falling from the
skies even the rain that now Falls
around them is putting out fires from
the plane crashes the world starts to
feel hopeful again after such an intense
turn of events in the film this reveal
gives viewers a meaningful moment of
tranquility and shows that Eric's
sacrifice had real meaning
foreign
[Music]